الان في قلب مخيم جباليا منذ الصباح
الغارات لم تتوقف على مخيم جباليا
بالتحديد وعلى منطقه الترنس ومنطقه المركز
مدفعيه الاحتلال اطلقت ما يقارب اكثر من
100 قذيفه حتى اللحظه في هذه المنطقه هناك
حاله من الرعب والخوف عند المواطنين جراء
هذا القصف المتواصل والغارات المستمره
بالتاكيد الغارات ترتكز في عده اماكن كما
نسمع هذه الاصوات غارات ترتكز في منطقه
مركز جباليا ومنطقه الترنس وشارع الهوجه
لم تتوقف نهائيا هناك عدد من الاصابات
جراء تساقط الشظايا في عده اماكن على
المواطنين هناك اطلاق نار بشكل مباشر من
طائرات كوات كوبتر في هذه الاماكن
ايضا هناك تمركز للاليات في عده محاور في
مخيم جباليا في منطقه فالوجه ومنطقه السته
الشهداء كما نسمع هذه الاصوات مستمره منذ
ساعات لم تتوقف قذائف المدفعيه
اي على المنازل وعلى المواطنين وعلى
الشوارع قصف شديد وعنيف وعنيف عنيف على
الطور ونابل صوت مش قادرين نستحمل وغزه
خنقنا فينا خ حمل رساله للعالم في نا لسه
فو جاي ورانا دخيل الله يمكن قصفهم لانه
طول واحنا ماشيين والقصف علينا
والله مش قادرين مش قادرين نتحمل يا اخنا
رايحين على عياده الوكاله كون امن شويه
والله بيتنا بنيناه جديد سبناه
ورحلنا الاحتلال يحاول من خلال اطلاق عدد
من القذائف على المنازل وعلى الاماكن
المقتضى
بالسكان في محاوله
لتهجيرهم كما نشاهد هنا تصاعد الدخان من
المكان نتيجه القصف المستمر في هذه
المنطقه هذه المنطقه بالتحديد شمال عياده
الوكاله شارع الهوجه مازال تصاعد الدخان
مستمر حتى هذه اللحظه كما نسمع القذائف لم
تتوقف نهائيا في هذه
الاماكن طبعا هذه المناطق مليئه
بالمواطنين
وبنازير التي يتم استهدافها بشكل مباشر لا
نعلم ماذا يريد الاحتلال من خلال استهدافه
بشكل مباشر للنازحين وللمواطنين ولهذه
الاماكن التي تعتبر امنه لكن حتى اللحظه
لا يوجد اي مكان امن في قطاع
غزه الجميع
مستهدف كما نشاهد هنا حاله الرعب والخوف
عند الاهالي بسبب القصف المستمر على مخيم
جباليا هذا قصف يعني وين بدنا نروح فيش
ملاج يعني وين العالم راحت العالم رسالتنا
للعالم تتحرك اذا في ضمير حي في انسان
تتحرك اذا فيش انسان خلص تبونا نموت موت
بطيء اخوي متصاوب مرمي بين الحياه والموت
وين وين الحقق الانسان وين الصليب
الاحمر كله ميت فش حدا ان رب العباد
شكوتنا لرب
العباد ربنا اللي بنصرنا ربنا اللي بعينا
رغم مئات القذائف رغم الصواريخ رغم الغزات
الغازات اللي بمو علينا الحارقه عايشين في
معسكر جباليه حتى نموت ندفن في معسكر
جباليه